welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to the society has just dropped on
Netflix and the ten-hour season has a
lot to unpack from it throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the show as
well as what I took from it this is full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen it
yet and don't want to know what happens
then I highly suggest that you turn it
off now without the way I just want to
thank you for clicking this video now
sit back relax and let's get into my
breakdown of the society the society is
a Lord of the Flies esque
teenage drama that follows a group of
young students who are during a field
trip find themselves in a replica of
their hometown with one big cubby it all
of the adults in the area are gone the
town has had a mysterious odor around it
for the past couple of days and this
seems to be linked to the disappearance
of the majority of the city citizens
there's apparently no way in or out of
the town or any evidence of anything
beyond it
West Ham and the society becomes just
that a group of people struggling to
create their own community without
imploding on one another
initially Newham seems like a paradise
where young people are no longer judged
by their parents prejudices and this
allows them to live a life of partying
where the fun never seems to end like
all good things though it must Cassandra
played by Rachel Keller appoints herself
as the leader but unfortunately she
isn't strong enough to stop the ensuing
chaos that inevitably will spring forth
from a group of high schoolers being
told that they are now the rulers of the
town naturally cliques form and this
causes complex as people become more and
more territorial we slowly realize that
society as a whole when reduced to
something without rules can lead to dire
consequences the group's tried to form
their own order but in doing so quickly
fall into the cliches that they
originally hated and were trying to
escape from this is a true debate before
our eyes on the positives and negatives
of socialism democracy communism and
capitalism that is far more mature than
the carrot
that it portrays for the show what I
love about the society is that the
characters are forced to confront and
accept that they took everything for
granted
their privilege has been something that
they never really considered and when
they are put in a position without it
they struggled to get by cassandra has
to deal with the fact that there are
many people who resent her new position
of power and influence and ultimately
she becomes the focus rather than the
danger of the paranormal happening that
caused most of the population to
disappear
she's berated as no longer being the
class president and the show does an
outstanding job of showcasing just how
little elective positions of power
actually are once the rules are stripped
away eventually she succumbs to this and
is put in the firing line at due to
people's fate of her this doesn't make
things easier for those put in power
either with the majority of the newly
appointed leaders in the season being
unable to handle the pressure
Ali struggles to deal with this route
and it becomes clear that in making one
decision while some will be happy many
will not the show successfully cements
the two sides of society with law duty
reason and protection of the weak having
to go head-to-head with ruling through
fear mob mentality and tyranny the
subtext here is outstanding it's a very
well-developed show in terms of
metaphors and meaning there are trials
executions and an election that sees the
society slowly turn into a real one the
show in the end action respects its
characters and does show that teenagers
if put in the right position can make
correct decision and grow the show has a
six-month time jump that allows it to
showcase how the actions of the group
have repercussions and it portrays the
characters well in this huge
coming-of-age story the season 1 finale
ends with Ali and well removed from
their leadership positions after a coup
is staged by Campbell and Lexi this
sends the election at the show is being
building up to off the rails but not
everything is as simple as it seems
Lexi talks like she's dead set on
removing Ali however she knows deep down
that she can't really handle the
pressure herself the ending is a focus
on how easy it is to judge those making
difficult choices
however when those choices are given to
you that doesn't mean that you have the
strength to make the tough decisions no
matter how good of a crate you are
though the society have shown that they
are very judgmental to people like Juhi
that doesn't however mean
well and Ali will fall victims to this
Ali has so much experience that it would
be stupid for Lexy to kill her as she's
the only one who truly knows what it's
like to lead there's also the fact that
that can't really be any major changes
once the to our house did everything has
a balance currently and the new leaders
will likely not wanted to stabilize this
which cements on how civilization is
built on certain expectations and that
politicians can be very little when it
comes to changing the big issues the
fact is people have to do things they
don't want to from time to time there
must be rules put in place and jobs in
order to get stability in people's lives
in order to quote run this town how it
should be run there isn't much that the
new leaders can do and they will no
doubt realize in the second season how
difficult Ali's shoes are to fill sure
she made some missteps in finding her
feet but she was never qualified for the
position anyway going forward I can see
Lexi relying on Ali for advice unless
the townfolk will realize that nothing
has really changed with her still making
the tough decisions
this will cause even more writing with
the town overturning the new leaders in
order to reappoint her as Ali said Lexie
making people hater is easy but once
that goes away there's nothing else you
can use
and I think season two will have a big
focus on this the next big thing season
two should tackle but probably won't is
why all the adults have disappeared I've
seen many theories with the majority of
people believing that this is all pop an
alien or government experiment but I
actually think it's to do with the
multiverse it's paid lip-service in the
finale and seems like it makes the most
sense the school buses clearly drop them
off in a replica city rather than their
home which is why things like the
graffiti were missing there's very clear
allusions to the Pied Piper with the
mysterious bus driver seeming to have
led the children away after the town's
fog refused to pay him for clearing the
smell I believe that he has escorted
them to a parallel dimension and it's
doing this to punish the parents for
their greed in the end we see that the
parents are still alive and are clearly
mourning the ones that have disappeared
and they still live in the same town and
are thriving once more however these
children may to be put in danger by the
return of the force that took their
and I can see this becoming a big plot
point when it returns all in all I hope
it's something to do with Thanos but I
guess we'll find out in season two
obviously I love to hear your thoughts
on the show and what your theories are
going forward
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out my full
breakdown on the newly released a
chapter 2 trailer which would be linked
at the end if you'd like to support the
show and get something back make sure
you check out our heavy spoilers
merchandise which would be linked below
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to deafen issue thanks again
for taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]